- There's a fuck
load of 50-year-olds
that think their life is over.
That think it's over
'cause they've been playing
for 30 years professionally,
they're tired, they've been
an accountant for 30 years,
they hate it but
they don't see any way out
because they don't realize
that there's Instagram Live.
'Cause they don't realize that
there's Facebook Groups.
'Cause they don't
realize that they can do a blog.
'Cause they don't realize
that they're a great writer
and if they did 14
Medium posts they can blow up
and so I'm on a mission
to get them to understand
that there're still 30,
40 years of amazing things.
Modern health, these
people are gonna be healthy
for another 30 years.
30!
You know how much shit you can
get done in 30 years, Avi?
You were 14 30 years ago, Av.
- [Avi] That's correct.
- How old are you?
- [Other Tyler] 23.
- You were fucking
negative seven, mother fucker.
(Avi laughs)
This mother fucker
was negative seven.
(light music)